welcome to the vcast and the bleacher
report app um we have a very special
show today um have one of my favorite
people on that I've that I've um been
able to play with and one of the um guys
I'm a huge fan of his game um and
everything about him man this is my dog
man but but first before we join him I
want to talk about the bills Jets game
it was crazy um from the very first
kickoff um we knew it was going to be a
special day um Reggie Gilliam forced to
Fumble on the opening kickoff like I
don't think I've ever been a part of a
game where we actually caused a turnover
on the kickoff and the funny thing about
that is coach mcder actually played um
the Texas an& them Aggie 12 man and
those guys running down on kickoff so it
was it was a special video for me me me
being from Texas A&M um but for us to
replicate that um on Sunday was amazing
and then the 12thman kickoff team
actually forced a fumble on on their
kickoff as well in the game on on
Saturday versus abene Christian so it
was a very very um interesting day it
started off you know by force fumble by
the guys on on the kickoff team we got a
field goal out of that and we just
started to get the ball moving before
you know it we had nine points um went
into Hal time 16 to six which has been
new for us usually we're battling out
and the game is very very close but to
have the momentum at halftime it kind of
gave us a lot of um encouragement to
just go out there and finish the game
and you know Josh played well everybody
played well it was a great team win and
I feel like that's what we needed to get
this thing going um defense played well
offense played well and now we have a
huge stretch of big dogs coming up from
the Eagles the Chiefs and the Dallas
Cowboys but before we get on to that man
let me introduce my guest Patrick C 10
hey I I appreciate you for coming on the
show my boy how are
you man I'm good man appreciate you for
having me on
dog man Pat was a unanimous
All-American in college he was the sec's
defensive play of the year in
2020 the ninth pick of the 2021 draft
first team all proo and pro bowler in 22
Patrick ceran how has it been making
that that jump from Alabama foot
football to Denver Bronco football or
League football has it been um easy I
know it's been easy you making it look
easy out
there yeah uh you could say easy um it's
just a start but like uh I say the
process was easier because going into my
rookie year you know I had guys like you
you know Kareem Justin those guys just
really you know put you know you put me
under your wings so uh the adjustment
was pretty easy and being able to see
the Brotherhood and the camaraderie
around the locker room was was what
really stood out for me because you know
having that at Bama then Carri carried
along within the league uh it was pretty
dope to see but you know being around
y'all every day and just making plays on
the field I mean adjustment was pretty
easy for
sure man I I know you I I know you knew
that you could play in the league from
day one and I knew too um you know I've
been saying how telling to you were
since last season on the vcast even
before then but last season on the vcast
I wore my Patrick t ceran shirt on the
show did you did you see that that
episode I think it was with uh Michael
Parsons I had the shirt on on the show
you rocking you rocking the president
well you you say you're the president of
the fan club huh yeah man I am the
President of the Patrick ceran fan club
and I had that established even way
before I remember when I got traded I
was like hey can I still be president of
of the Patrick ceran fan club even
though I'm playing for round that was
crazy man it's dope to see you man
develop man and continue to develop man
and you really have no limit man it's
just um a honor and a privilege to to
just be able to witness it from a very
very early age and you know I I like to
say I've been in the read this is my
13th year in the league and it's only
been a few players that I have seen jump
from college to second year in the
league and you did that like you was you
were never a rookie like it was only out
13 years and I've been around a lot of
good rookies been around a lot of great
players you know you and Jerry Judy were
the two players that I've seen just
automatically come into the league at
year two is it is it something that
y'all doing Alabama is there something
that y'all do in Alabama that gets y'all
ready for the league or it didn't matter
if you went to Alabama or
not uh I I'll say Alabama played a huge
point in that um just Alabama from the
standpoint of the resources and allowing
us to be engaged within and just
understanding what they had to possess
to take you to the next level and I just
think me and Jerry's very locked in from
that standpoint understanding you know
what they have to offer and from the
first day I stepped on into campus you
know I was very locked in on my goals
and aspirations which was making it to
this point I am right now and Alabama
did a great job of doing that but it
just started with
understanding the goals I wanted to
reach and you know obviously Alabama
help but it started in high school uh
till then so it's it's honestly a
blessing you know just looking back at
it and just understanding through the
vocal point of my career where I'm at
now uh you know Alabama played a huge
part of it so man let's let's go back
before Alabama man let's go back to high
school where you were a five-star
recruit of course you was a festar
recruit and you won backto back high
school state championships with your dad
as the head coach how was how was that
like how your dad played in the league
man how was that you know having your
dad be your coach and win back-to-back
state championship there's a lot of guys
that play a lot of football and to win
the state championship in high school
with your pops like how was that
experience you know sharing that with
your with your
dad it it was pretty surreal uh to be
honest because being able to share that
moment with him on the field and having
that Father and Son Bond uh combined
with you know the coaching and you know
him being the coach as well uh it was it
was a different experience for me and a
different perspective uh from me from my
teammates but you know just going out
there each and every day grinding and uh
winning state championship at the state
championship it was honestly one of the
Fondest Memories I could ever remember
uh
because those experiences man this what
shap me up to what I'm to what I am now
and just focus on winning day in and day
out so but having that experience with
pots was a very special moment in my
life you know so uh you know going back
on those memories it was enjoyable to
experience that with my teammates back
in the day so man that's dope man I I
can only imagine man back to back state
championships man but moving on from
your your high school career to your
college career you entered signing day
as the number number one quarterback
recruit in the country everybody
expected you to go to LSU but you chose
you chose
Alabama your dad also played for Nick
svon as well in Miami with the dolphins
did it did this have any impact on your
decision to leave and not go to LSU and
go to
Alabama well you know what's funny
because so my family all my family from
Louisiana they from new wers so I had
some Louisiana TI I me I i' I've always
been an LSU fan since I was a young like
I can
remember that one uh national
championship against when they play
Alabama and they lost uh I was pretty
heartbroken that's how big of a fan I
was but it always been it always been at
you from the jump then you know once
recruiting come and you you know Vis
visit these schools and you get to talk
to these coaches you see you know the
real of college football and I just
think Alabama was just check after check
after check and I just feel like that
was the best school for me uh to build
on my career so I just pick Alabama on
that standpoint for
sure man you you definitely did not make
any mistakes for sure um you know
Alabama Alabama they had a dynasty there
you know since 2000 Alabama leavs all
all colleges with 46 NFL first round
picks six of those first round picks
coming from your class in
2021 um it was the most Alabama uh
players drafted ever in the first round
Jaylen Wilder Devon Smith M Jones n Naji
Harris Alex Leatherwood and of of course
um you know yourself all in that class
and you all won the the the national
championship together in 2020 how cool
was it to see so many um of your
teammates going to first
round yeah man it pretty I don't know we
got the or no for I I don't know if it's
I don't know if it's a record but y'
y'all I mean y it's got to
be it's got to be but I mean since 2000
you know Alabama leagues all colleges
with 46 first round picks I know Miami
had Miami had some you know some guys
get drafted too but I don't know about
46 my BR so y' gota have the record bro
like how how was it to see so many of
your teammates that you was in college
that you were in a college locker room
with now they're your colleagues around
the NF F and Y all got drafted on the
same day bro that's that's go to be
that's got to be surreal too y had to
have talked about that too as well like
back at
Alabama yeah it's just great to see and
that's just a testament towards Alabama
and what they produce you know year in
and year out but our class is pretty
special uh we had a hman winner and
Devonte Smith we had you know Jayden W
Naji Harris you know Alex lewood you
know those guys Matt Jones so um when
you look back at that class and what
they doing now was pretty special to see
because we was all bought in and all
locked in and we was one of the few
classes where you know sa and really
allowed us
to you know be captains of the team and
you know just lead that team towards you
know the national championship and just
to have those select few guys in the
first round you know it's pretty special
to
see you know you know I'mma turn you
against some of those uh what they call
them elephants over there they they call
it the tide I'm have to turn you against
some of your the past teams in Alabama
do you think the 2020 team was the best
Alabama team
ever I think for sure I think if it's
not one then it's number two that's how
I feel about it I think we was just so
complete you know during that year
during the co year um we had some
setbacks because obviously we didn't
have a full schedule but just for us to
be able to be locked in for us to come
together as a team during that tough
time and win a National Championship uh
it was just it just goes to show you
know our commitment of excellence and I
can honestly say that's one of the
funnest years I've had at Alabama so uh
just being around that group of guys a
special group of guys was pretty awesome
to see and obviously topping it off with
natti
so
right peep this stat right here Alabama
curent and former players have made over
1.9 billion dollars under Nick
Sabin if you if you include the most
recent draft class that's well over two
billion
do Nick
Sabin yeah $2 billion do worth of player
contracts in the
league that's that's that's insane how
do you how do you feel coach saving you
know gets everybody prepared for the NFL
is what is it that he does that that has
everybody
ready I just think the way how he um
goes about things uh he really teaches
us like the Dynamics of Excellence you
know what I mean just never being
complacent um you know always having a
strong work ethic uh day in and day out
and I just believe that propelled us to
exceed certain levels um obviously we
had you know the three star four star
five star recruits but for him to be
able to establish that Legacy and
establish you know that Excellence is
just a testament to him and what he does
for the players around him and uh you
know it's just going to keep on building
I just think it's never going to go away
uh for as long as for as long as he want
to be in college so uh you know just
during those experien I learned a lot
from him in Alabama from a school
standpoint
man that's that's dope early in the
season you know fans were writing off
Alabama after one loss now they're
ranked number eight um and with the SEC
Championship right around the corner
they're playing Georgia um all they had
to do is beat Georgia and they'll be
back in the in the college football
playoffs what is your predictions on
that game Georgia I mean they look good
then sometimes they look like it looks
like you know they can be beat but when
they're when they're firing that all
sers really if you think about all the
big the big dogs like when they're
firing at all cylinders they're hard to
be beat but what do you think about um
you know Alabama Georgia SEC
Championship I think I think it's gonna
be a great game but obviously I got
Alabama winning about 14 at least I
think because what I see you know what
I've seen these past couple weeks I've
seen Alabama like they offense come
alive like they're looking more complete
uh you know jayen he's throwing the ball
more they look more confident and you
know it's it's hard to beat a confident
team with all the momentum swinging you
know on their Sid
so uh you know I think I think Georgia
got their work cut out for him for sure
but uh I obviously Georgia is a great
team B's a great team I think it's gonna
be a great game all around but you know
I got the tide on
top of course of course you know if
y'all beat Georgia you know y'all be
y'all most likely be in the college
football playoffs you know they're
expanded a TW a 12 team college football
playoff next year that's that's insane
we already got the nil now they got TW
they got a 12 team college football
playoff what do you I mean what do you
think is what it's obviously good in the
in in college that's I'm not saying it's
not good but what do you think about you
know the Ken State a college football
college athletics and the 12 team
college football expansion um that they
have next
year yeah uh you know college the brand
you know I mean it's just I just feel
like all that goes into negotiating for
the money you know what I mean but at
the end of the day I think it's great
for the fans uh great for college
football fans to see more teams in the
playoffs because I think it make it more
uh intriguing to see um more fun to
watch because I feel like these teams
that's you know one lost two lost teams
I think they deserve a shot at it and
you know just expanding you know the
playoffs and get those teams opportunity
to showcase what they got espec
especially against relevant teams you
know that's um in towards focusing on
winning National Championship so I think
it's a great thing for college football
and the
fans it it definitely is man when you
was in when you were in college man um I
I just knew it you know I knew you knew
it and I just I just knew it man I don't
played a lot of football and been around
a lot of great players and they always
say the rushian coverage goes together
so it's just I'm just able to see what
good cornerbacks look like and you know
at the beginning of the show like I said
I knew you were going to be a special
talent from the very very beginning and
I and I knew this when we drafted you
you know I was so excited when we
drafted you man we we got this video we
got the video from when you know the
Denver Broncos took you right
here
n
Broncos I told you I told you come
on let's do
it hey you know russan coverage go
together man rushan coverage go together
man um you know I just knew like man
having you there man and I you know I
play with Champ Bailey and you know I
was you know I was there for Champs last
three years in Denver man so I just I
just knew that we were going in that
direction man and we had already had
Justin Simmons and I just knew like this
was like the perfect combination of of
everything man and when we picked you
man I was so excited man how's you know
how has it been you know how's it being
being in Denver broncco I know you love
it um you had a you had a great uh
rookie season you know even your pop
shouted you out you know you had 58
tackles 45 solo tackles 14 passes
defended four interceptions and one
touchdown as a rookie man you know how
is it how has it been these these first
couple of years in the league and in
Denver uh has been great uh I just
believe that each and every experience
each and every year you know I learned
something new about the team and about
the league but I could say that it's
been great
because you know obviously I had three
new coaching changes but I just feel
like the standard never switch I just
feel like everybody was on track obv you
know you know from defense and how he
really like hone in on defense and you
know winning ball games on the defensive
side of all so you know that never went
away then obviously the Brotherhood and
the karate we have with the lock room is
pretty you know fascinating to see but I
could say you know each and every year
I've gotten better um this year I could
say I really honed in on being a leader
you know on the field from a vocal
standpoint you know just leading the
boys uh just like how you you know
viewed us when we was the young PS but
now you know taking on that role and you
know leading the rookies and the younger
guys and you know Paving away for them
so they could come in and you know Excel
as well too so uh like I say each and
every experience you learn something new
and it's been great so far yeah I
remember um my very first time like at
practice with Pat and you know I forgot
coach was talking to him about something
and I like wait I was standing by him
for a second and I like looked down and
I saw his shoes I was like bro like what
what size of those shoes and you was
like bro I wear a size 13 I was like man
you wear a size 13 I wear a size 12 like
you nickel and and corner and all stuff
with a size 13 he was like yeah bro
that's that just what I do man and I and
I watched you like battle with courland
and you know play the nickel and do all
of these things that I have never seen a
a rookie DB do man and I knew it before
you got here and I knew when you was
there man I knew that you was going to
have um you know excellent excellent
career and then then to go a step
further I just knew by talking to you
that you really understood like your
goals and what you wanted to do and all
of this NFL stuff wasn't it really
wasn't anything for you and I knew that
just of short conversations with you man
and I just knew like man I don't need to
tell him nothing I don't need to tell
him nothing about nothing all I got to
do is just tell him about himself man
and how great he could be man and as a
leader like we were talking about
earlier you know you you try to find
ways to inspire your teammates and get
them to play at a level that they
wouldn't normally play at and you
already had that that spark man so it's
just been great you know to uh be a part
of that man and to witness that you know
um in our time in Denver man I always uh
you know keep that close by my by my
heart as long along with the other great
players that I've been around man so
hats off to you man you said that you
want to play in Denver for your entire
career I felt the same way um what makes
Denver so special to
you uh I I just think the city is great
man um I've grown accustom to it just
the love that the people show and
obviously it's weird at first it's weird
at first but then you like oh yeah yeah
I see why I like it now yeah you you see
like you can see why like the the
organization had so much success in the
past because you know everybody's all
into it seeing what the Broncos up to
you know around the city so you know
it's just it's just been great so far
and you know obviously I I love the way
how the team's structure right now and I
just can't wait to bu on it and you know
the more and more I just go experience a
city in Colorado the more dope people
you meet so um I've grown into it for
sure for sure man I loved it I loved it
too man I was there for um was it 11 and
I was there for 11 and a half years man
and you know I totally um you know
bought in being a a a Coloradoan for
life and I'm still a Coloradoan man I
still say weed when talking about the
Denver Broncos I don't think um um you
know you can ever erase 11 and a half
years bro I still watch every single one
of y'all games like I'm playing in those
games man and you know I talked to y'all
about um you know the state of the
Denver Broncos as well at courtland's
weding and you know talking about um sea
Peyton and the type of coach that he is
man you know you got a new coach and
Shawn Peyton what was the transition
like what kind of culture did he bring
to to Denver when he got
there uh I mean obviously his resume
speaks for itself uh you talking about a
guy that's won a Super Bowl and been to
playoffs like numerous amount of times
so I got the feeling that he was just
trying to bring in that win winning
standard and you know from the first day
he got here until now he's always
focused on winning and always focused on
seeing what's best for his players and
he's going to bring the best out you for
sure but he also has a little Swagger to
him I could say that as well because uh
you know how confident he is and you
know his ability to you know lead a team
to the promised land so it's been
nothing but great so far um he is what
he is on paper and you know he's even
better in person so uh it's it's just
been great you know just being able to
work with him day in and day out so man
you can see that confidence man he he's
walking around the sideline with those
Jordans on I I really like everything
that he's done except for one thing he
let go of Brandon mcmanis I thought that
y'all really you know needed a kicker um
it's been times where Brandon could have
came through for you guys but hey that's
just part of the business I love
everything that he's done with the
Denver Broncos except that decision man
um you know I've also loved Russ being
there you've been able to play with Russ
for you know a couple of Seasons now
what's it like playing with Russ I knew
Russ before he came to the den Broncos I
knew he was gonna be able to do a great
job you know we shared a uh a mental
coach and Trevor moad so um I love love
the Insight that Trevor had for me and
that that he had for Russ but you know
what's it like uh you know what's it
like playing with Russ what's it like
having him in a locking
room R Russ is great uh he he's always
been a guy that you know put his
teammates first before him uh he's just
always positive uh always shining the
light on others um he just speaks
positive affirmations around the locker
room man when you got a guy like
lead in the team especially at
quarterback you ain't got nothing but to
you know respect him for what he is and
OB he does great work in the community
uh this and that but he's just a great
person to be around uh and his play his
play speaks for itself uh obviously he's
got a what Super Bowl how many Super
Bowls he got he got one should have two
you know all they had to do is run the
ball in the second one but that's that's
uh you know that's something else that
we won't talk about here on this show
but you Russ Russ has been great and one
of the things that I that I really like
about Russ whenever I watch his uh
interviews especially after hard games
or you know challenging games where
y'all have lost he he always says that
I'm G get it right and I'mma keep
working until I do that's that's all I
know how to do and that hit home for me
last year hit home for me this year and
I'm not even on a team man and I and I
just uh love the way Russ you know talks
man how does uh how does you know Russ
and Shawn Peyton compliment each
other uh I could say Russ and Sean are
two completely different people uh but
they compliment each other well
because they're they got different
personalities which is unique because it
meses in a way I mean you got Sean
that's you know uh you know just his
personality speaks for itself you know
he's very confident uh you GNA talk is
talk walk is walk but you know you got
rest deserve but also a competitor he's
quiet so I think they bring the best out
of each other and which is great you
want to see that compliment you know out
of your coach and quarterback and you
know over time during the duration of
the Season you can see the relationship
you know starting to grow and grow which
is a great thing to
see man it's uh yeah they've been able
to to you know come through the the the
bad times and now it's the good times
there in Denver man had a rough you know
start to the season a lot of trade talks
you know around the uh the Denver
Broncos um how was the vibe in the
locker room during that time what was it
like seeing your name pop up in those
conversations I thought they was I
thought I was going to see it pop up to
come to Buffalo but they they obviously
know man they obviously know not to do
nothing crazy like that how was it what
was it like seeing your name pop up in
those conversations
though I ain't going to lie it was like
you said during that time when we was
shoot one and5 it was tough man and it
was it was
like we was just fighting for a win but
we just couldn't get a win and obviously
trade talks come during the trade
deadline but Sean was very committed
into saying like I'm not trading nobody
I'm keeping the team how it is because
he's really big on building the team
rather than finding something and try to
put him the light but uh it was it was
it was kind of tough because obviously
you don't want to get traded uh but NFL
is a business at the same time uh so
when I see my name in the trade talks it
was like I can only control what I could
control at the end of the day but uh
once I talked to Sean and once I talked
to you know ownership you know around
the building it was like we want to keep
you here you know that's a mindset
around the whole building which is
great man that's that's great man you
know at least they talked to you about
it I had no idea I just came to to work
and they said vun you going to Los
Angeles it it wasn't you know that bad
for me obviously but I want to stay at
Denver Bronco I want to stay at Denver
Bronco through the thick through the
thin I want to be part of the solution
but hey everything works out you got a
great team now um the Broncos are on a
on a four game win streak um you know
I've been saying since even before the
season started that you guys are going
to turn it around what's clicking for
the team right now um did it take you
know y'all losing about 70 points to to
bring out the dog and everybody or or
you know did it take like you know any
crazy speeches in the locker room like
what did it take to really wake up the
sleeping giant of the demver
Broncos yeah man uh after that Miami
game we really had to like self-reflect
and look upon ourselves on like what
what type of team we wanted to be
because after that game it's there not
much you could look at but it's it's
something what you you learn a lot from
that game to see what type of Team you
want to be moving forward and I
think during that period you know guys
really bought in and locked in to
Excellence and you know our confidence
never wavered because next week we went
into Chicago we was down
217 then we came back and won the ball
game which was huge for us in our
confidence and know after that game uh
who we we played the Jets I believe we
lost but even even after the loss man we
still stay confident we still
believe in what we had going on then uh
we play the Packers we won then we play
the Chiefs then we just going on this
win streak which is still going alive to
this day and you know it's just a
testament to what type of team and what
type of car do we have man because it
was a rough few weeks uh during the
first couple games of the season but man
we figured it out which is a great thing
because you you know it's it's a long
season and a lot of ball to be played
and you know once you get it together
once you click on all cylinders you know
it's we a very dangerous team and we
starting to be like
that yep man for sure man you know um is
there are there any are there any
teammates that you want to celebrate
while you have the spotlight to talk
about the Denver Broncos I'll go first
courland Sutton oh my God this guy this
guy is playing out of his mind courland
Sutton this offensive line is playing
very very solid too for Russ um I think
the inside linebacker play from
Singleton and Josie
has been great you know they come
downhill Josie had a pressure on dos
that forced the interception y were able
to change momentum in the game on Sunday
night I think the cornerback play and
the secondary play of course has been
good Brandon
Browning um Cooper and Nico ni Bonito
these guys are playing out of their mind
right now along with Perkins I didn't
didn't even play with none of those guys
but I but I I watch man and I know man
these guys are playing out of their mind
as well the inside um the interior
lineman play has been well really the
defense has really tanged around Jerry
Judy kinson everybody is is coming alive
man but I think it starts with courland
sun he's playing out of his mind
quarterback play has been um extremely
well from Russ as well he's he hasn't
turned the ball over he's been taking
the conservative uh passes and the plays
and they're turning into big plays so
you know um I just want to shout those
people out but I want to hear from
Patrick ctan is there anybody on your
team that that you want to shout out for
the Denver
Broncos
I want to shout out two
people uh on the defensive side of the
ball uh jquan McMillan or Nichol slot uh
yes sir he's a baller he's been making
plays left and right he made a play
against y'all but I don't wanna I don't
wanna uh we gonna talk about that here
in a second it's all
good yeah but man he's been he he's the
guy you talk about he he went undrafted
he came in and he just put his head down
at work and now he finally got his
opportunity and he's just showcasing his
talent especially on Prim Time games
these past games he's really been
balling out and another guy I want to
mention is DJ Jones uh in front working
in d line he's a force man and he's
really causing Havoc for opposing
offensive lineman offensive guards
because he's he's really he just sheds
blocks and is very disruptive Back Field
and we need that type of pressure in the
defense and he's been playing great ball
as well too but I just say as a as a
team you know there's just a lot of guys
that's came in and you know stepped up
and been making plays for us on this run
and on his
stretch man in um the stretch that you
uh that you guys went on one of those
teams were against the Buffalo Bills
that was so you know playing for me
playing in Denver Broncos I didn't want
to make it um it was just another team
right that's what I told myself that's
what I went into it talking to the media
it really was just another it really was
just another game I felt the difference
actually on game day when I walked into
the stadium and flip was standing in the
same spot that he normally stands at
because we would come play the Buffalo
Bills and flip would be in the same spot
and I was walking past and I didn't even
see flip right there and he was just
like hey V what's up and I looked over
and it just felt like it was a blast
from the past and I was I was back on
the Denver Broncos for some Reon it was
crazy bro that was one moment um when I
went out for preseason I saw you I saw
PJ lock and I saw you man it just felt
like I was it felt like I was on the
teaming and it was like a weird
situation I was like man I know so many
people over here but I'm on this side
and then this is this is what cap the
weirdness for me I was obviously a
captain going against my old team and
walking across obviously I played Russ a
million times that was normal went
against mlinci a couple of times that
was normal but seeing Courtland sudden
over here like my dog like I was like
bro like what's I was like bro what's
going on and it was like man do I do I
hug him like do I can we talk a little
bit like we we did the coin TOs and we
got ready to run off and like we both
made eye contact and I was like he kind
of looked at me like do we hug again do
we shake hands again then it was like
just the in it was like no I'm going
over here and you going over there like
we on separate teams but there was no
way I could have prepared for seeing be
prepared for you know seeing all of my
old like like my dogs cuz you know it
wasn't always great in Denver man and we
you know we we thugged it out and when
you Thug it out as a as a team like that
it builds the camaraderie it builds the
love for you know your your teammates
and you you can never ever break that
Bond and there was no way that I could
have prepared myself for those um
emotions or those moments in the game
still want to win the game um we had
four turnovers um your defense plays
well actually we turned the ball over in
the first play of the game that's
neither here nor there um it was just a
crazy game it went all the way down to
the the end of the game the guy misses
the field goal but we have 12 people on
the field get another kick and he barely
scrapes it in through the through the
right uh upfield uh and and it was just
crazy man I would have loved to like
like stayed there and like chopped it up
with all of you guys bro but as you know
man I I couldn't I couldn't do it man I
I couldn't I couldn't to be honest
saying it on the show to my dog I
couldn't bear losing to my my old team
and then kissing y'all ass after the
game I just had to I just had to get out
I just had to get out of there man but
it's all love and respect man how was
how was it how was it how was it for
y'all
man it was like you said it was a lot of
emotions High Rising emotions throughout
that game man because like you said we
missed the field goal then the penalty
came and boom we made the field goal but
you know throughout that game we battled
through so much adversity because y'all
had a drive where y'all scored it was a
long touchdown drive before on that last
drive we had to uh you know clinch the
game with a field goal but man we was we
was going into that game ready to win
because obviously y'all have a great
team uh you know nobody believed in us
we was an underdog so we had to pass
interference on on third down we we
can't forget the pass interference on
Third and 10 you know that would have
sealed the game but that's neither
that's neither here thereo it was a lot
of emotions in that game for sure you
gota go with the game how it's called
bro but uh yeah it was a lot of emotion
man uh I can't imagine for you because
you know obviously you playing against
you know your old team against former
teammates I know your emotions running
high but you know I just feel like that
whole game was full of emotions and when
we came out and won that game you know
everybody was feeling great especially
on Prime Time showcasing that you know
this ain't the team you know that y seen
in the past you know this a new team
that we building so I think it's just a
great Victory all around so uh it was
man it was man and I couldn't have said
it I probably wouldn't have said it then
but the truth is and I say it now man
y'all got a good team man I'm still a
fan of all of you guys man um Garett B
you know Justin Simmons yourself um
there's just so many guys that I can I
would I would root for any day of the
week even if we were playing you know
you guys are not man and you know we're
both um currently on the outside looking
in as far as the playoff picture but
we've both teams have great momentum
after some really big dubs um let's take
a look at the current AFC playoff
pitcher you know what do you think both
teams need to do to be a part of the
playf off uh
conversation y done playing the Steelers
I mean y done playing the Chiefs y play
the Texans what is it December 23rd
playing the Texans what do you think
basically y'all just gota y gotta win
out what team do y'all have this
week we got the Browns so that's that's
another pivotal matchup uh CU true the
Browns in it right now so
uh yeah this this a big game for us
coming this week and uh
so I just feel like we both of us need
to win out Sho the rest of the schedule
I feel like the months of November and
December are huge uh during this time of
year because you know you got your
divisional opponents but also you got
crucial Big Time games uh against teams
that's you know in the playoff race so a
lot of things could happen for uh both
teams so as long as we you know win win
majority these games out I think you
know we'll be in good hands for sure
yeah man y y going to be a good hands
and really honestly I would say with my
what if I was on your team and my advice
to the Buffalo Bills is just what I say
in the locker room and I tell you guys
now like we can't really be worried
about it let's just take it one quarter
at a time like we play some of the big
dogs we got the Eagles the the Chiefs
and the Cowboys coming up let's just
focus on the first quarter of the Eagles
and just take it one court at a time and
let's uh continue to play man um you
know before we move on we gota we really
have to talk about some of the the
comments that Tom Brady made have you
heard the audio have you heard what he
said about the
league yeah yeah I heard
it well I haven't heard it let let me
see I I haven't heard it today's NFL I
don't see the Excellence that I saw in
the past why not and why not I think the
coaching isn't as as good as it was I
don't think the development of young
players is as good as it was the rules
have allowed a lot of bad habits to get
into that actual performance of the game
so I just think the product in my
opinion is less than what it's been I
think I look at a lot of players like
Ray Lewis and Rodney Harrison and Ronnie
lot and guys that impacted the game in
in a certain way and every hit they
would have made would have been a
penalty you hear coaches complaining
about their own player being tackling
and not necessarily why don't they talk
to their player about how to protect
himself we used to work on the
fundamental those things all the time
now they're trying to be regulated all
the time offensive players need to
protect themselves it's not up to the
defensive player to protect the
offensive player a defensive player
needs to protect himself I didn't throw
the ball to certain areas because I was
afraid players was going to get knocked
out that's the reality I didn't throw it
to the middle when I played Ray Lewis
because you knock him out of the game
and I couldn't afford to lose a good
player and um you know I would agree
with him but I will say that the league
it just has to continue to evolve and of
course you know if Ray Lewis and and and
L and those guys play today it' be
different I mean I think Kareem Jackson
he played the game at such a high level
and he was fear he's feared by so many
different players that it's just hard to
come out of that type of uh style of
play Man shout out to my guy Kareem man
and it's crazy what's going on with my
dog kjack man but the way the league is
these days is they're just hyper
sensitive to big hits like that if I
could if I could say it at his simplest
form I wouldn't say that the hit the hit
on dobs that was that was straighter
than chess like you know um but it's
just it's just crazy how the league is
and I think to a certain extent Tom
Brady is right but if we want to ensure
um the sustainability of our league we
have to continue to change the rules and
make it safer for not only offensive
players but for defensive players as
well and I have two young Sons so you
know for it has to be able to develop
for them to be able to play in the
league and be healthy after they're done
playing so I don't agree with it but I
think it is the right way to go to to to
sustain um our our league and to ensure
the growth and to make sure our kids can
play and there and they're safe to play
in the league as well 20 years from now
what do you think about
that yeah uh like you said like
throughout the years the game evolves
you know rules changes uh and obviously
it's
it's a circumstance with kareim because
it's unfortunate like you said because
his style of play always been you know
that's his way of playing the game you
know being physical um because you know
Karine he's not the biggest guy so no no
he's just he's just playing the game the
way he's used to and that's flying
around making plays and um obviously you
know with the rules changing you trying
to protect players from uh you know
certain consequences you know that's
leading on uh you know later on in their
Liv you don't want that to happen but I
just feel like there should be some
rules where you know there's some
leadway to this hit compared to this
other hit and how can we s of talk about
it in that way you know because
obviously head to head hits that's
something that's really a big factor in
the game and that needs to be talked
about even more but you know regular
regular hits like in the thigh pad
shoulder pad area I don't think it
should be big as a consequence as
someone HED somebody the head just due
to the factors of it but like I said
it's very unfortunate that it had to be
this way um and I know Kareem he's he's
very hurt about it you know because you
know he loves the game he loves to play
the game uh and he he just loves being
out there playing with his brothers and
you know just seeing him not being able
to play for these next four games it's
going to hurt the team a lot
so yeah man and shout out to my dog
kareim man you'll get through it man
recently Steve Smith Senor was asked
about who your game reminds him of and
he compared you to derel Rivas and Champ
Bailey two Hall of Fame players I would
say I don't want to make any comparisons
to PS2 because I I feel like the league
is all based on comparisons and whenever
you have great players they got to play
like somebody else and I'm here to say
Von Miller with my 133 years in the NFL
that you don't remind me anybody you
play the game at a at a at a very very
high level man and you know um Champ
Bailey I would say ah you kind of built
the same but I feel like you are your
your own player man that they got they
got me to thinking that there's been a
lot of great quarterbacks play this game
um who are your top five players of all
time your top five quarterbacks of all
time top five uh those two that you
mentioned they in there for sure
um reers and champ they they've been
guys that's been doing consistently year
in and year out um from what I remember
early in my years but I say guys like
you know Charles Woodson uh that's a
great another great player um then you
got like the Tha laws you know uh Sant
Samuels you know my pops you know I put
him in that category as well but got to
put sen you in there for sure yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and what about um besides you of
course you would be top on this list too
besides you which quarterbacks are the
best in the game right
now shoot right now
uh I say I say Ramy Ramsey gotta be uh
the guy I mean he's been he's been
holding the standard for so many years
uh Ramsey definitely
is in there um then I say I say uh guys
like Slay Slay Slay been doing it
consist year in and year out um then you
got the young guys like me sa and um you
know Wen and go guys like that but uh
see else I say Trey
Diggs um he's been doing it consistently
uh making
plays um and there's there's a there's a
young cat that's really B Don Bland for
the Cowboys I mean sh he got four pick
sixes I never heard of that before um
yeah czy his mind that's crazy uh yeah I
I just think there's so many great
Corners in this league that you could
put anybody it's like mix and match you
could swap guys out swap guys in it's
just so many great Corners in this
league so but if I was had to give a few
amount of guys I say though those guys
are for sure at the top of the list
and as president of the Patrick ceran
fan club I would say Patrick ceran is
definitely at the top of that list and
if it's not one he's two and he's not
two if you get what I'm saying before I
let you go I know you're huge on family
um y I know you got the family in town
man what are what are you what are your
Thanksgiving plans um are you going to
watch some football on Thanksgiving you
gonna have teammates come over what's
your favorite Thanksgiving dish are you
going to prepare a turkey what are they
doing over there at the Patrick Santan
um household for
Thanksgiving sureo man uh yeah they G to
throw down over here I got the the fam
in town uh you know it's always great to
spend family family time around this
time of the year because you know
obviously during the season you you
don't get to capture those moments but
having them in town it's a blessing but
yeah they GNA throw down I'm talking
about mac and cheese the yams cot greens
turkey ham you you know how it go but uh
I say my favorite dish is a yam man you
can't you can't go wrong with the Y
because you you only get that meal you
know once a year on Thanksgiving so I
say
the I say the Y is one of my favorites
for sure but um obviously I'm G watch
football uh lay down chill down a little
bit then you know eat great food but I
say the the the most appreciated part
about Thanksgiving and spending time
with family especially time you don't
get uh sometimes throughout the year so
you know very excited for
that are yall gonna bring out the
Uno yall play UNO I'm invited I'm
invited I'm invited teammates over to
the crib man playing Uno a deck of cards
you know so uh Spades whatever whatever
you want to whatever games I'm G have
here at the household so uh it's gonna
be it's gonna be a fun day for
sure all right Pat man I'm I'm going let
you go but first man I want to say I
love you man I appreciate you man if you
ever need me for anything man just let
me know man it could be
a a a FaceTime video with your cousin
man I would love to just help you out in
in any type of way man it's been love
from the start it's been all love from
my end and it'll be love forever my boy
and you know I cherish my my time that I
had with you man another great player
that I played with man and I love you
man and I want you to continue to be you
man I wish the Broncos the best y'all go
ahead and go crazy for the rest of the
season man like I said man if you ever
need me I got you man and I see you soon
I see you soon for sure my boy I'm sure
of it yeah you know it's all love man
appreciate you for having me dog we
gonna catch up soon for
sure all right my boy all right Pat I
appreciate you my boy um it's always
good to you know talk to my my guys man
Patrick 1 10 for show man um you know
this week we got the Eagles uh coming up
just saw of Eagles play last night it
was a very very tough game versus um the
Kansas City Chiefs which we play the
game after that so I feel like the
Kansas City Chiefs had momentum for a
long period of the game but the Eagles
have such a tough team man that they're
really never out of it especially with
Jaylen Herz and the offensive line that
they got but if we can just continue to
play a solid football that we play um
let this win that we have versus the
Jets continue to propel us to Greatness
I feel like we will be all right we'll
be great um let's just keep doing what
we do and we'll be great man we have the
Eagles and the the Kansas City Chiefs
and then the Dallas Cowboys but to get
through any of that is just one play at
a time so as always here on the vcast
it's always love and respect I
appreciate all you guys for for tuning
in see you guys next
[Music]
time